severus snape once said the dark arts
are many varied ever-changing and
eternal fighting them is like fighting a
mini-headed monster which each time a
neck is severed sprouts ahead even
fiercer and cleverer than before you are
fighting that which is unfixed mutating
indestructible since the announcement of
hogwarts legacy and its promise to put
players at the center of their adventure
allowing them to become the witch or
wizard they choose to be fans have
wondered and speculated as to just how
far we'll be able to go down the path of
dark magic we were given a taste of
things to come near the end of the
hogwarts legacy gameplay trailer in what
had to be the most jaw-dropping moment
of the entire showcase in this video
we'll take a closer look at how hogwarts
legacy may handle dark magic while
considering the history of the dark arts
in the wizarding world some of the
earliest information we have on the dark
arts comes to us through harry's eyes
and ears in his defense against the dark
arts classes at hogwarts which of course
is a confirmed class for hogwarts legacy
of course harry potter is the only known
wizard to have ever survived the killing
curse when voldemort attempted to take
his life on october 31st 1981 but how
exactly will this curse work in hogwarts
legacy how soon will we unlock it in the
game can it be used anywhere or any time
what about a down meter i believe there
are some clues we can look for in the
gameplay trailer that will help us
determine a little more about how this
curse will be used in the game our first
clue comes in the moment just before we
see avad kadavra in the trailer in the
lead up to that exact moment when we see
the curse cast on screen we hear the
narrator say be careful where you choose
to explore as it may lead you down a
darker path
now we've known for a while that
hogwarts legacy will give players a
choice over the type of wizard or witch
they wish to be there are still a lot of
details we don't know about how exactly
this will play out but the official faq
reads they will grow their characters
abilities by mastering powerful spells
brewing potions and harvesting magical
plants as they face off against deadly
enemies players will also encounter
missions and scenarios that will pose
difficult choices and determine what
they stand for so i believe this spell
will only be available for wizards or
witches who choose the dark path i don't
expect this to be something anyone can
use at any time another interesting bit
about avada cadaver is where we see it
being cast if you slow down the trailer
we can see what appears to be a basic
goblin on the other end of the curse and
it's in this large cavernous area with
seemingly no other enemies around this
is in stark contrast to the rest of the
trailer when pretty much any time we're
shown in combat it's in an area with
multiple enemies except for another
specific moment in the trailer when this
happens devastate your enemies using
various finishes
[Music]
you can even use the mysterious powerful
magic your professors do not understand
to obliterate your strongest foes
and so with this we're introduced to a
gameplay mechanic that's clearly going
to be a core part of the game and that
is the finishers first in this scene we
see the player character repeatedly
slamming the goblin with what could be a
more violent variation of descendo or
possibly something entirely new and the
next one is the lightning being summoned
from above which to everything i can
find isn't anything we've really seen in
the harry potter series before probably
the closest thing we've seen is when
voldemort first took possession of the
elder wand after dumbledore's death but
in that instance it wasn't used to kill
or destroy a living target given the
dialogue when this lightning moment
appears on screen it's pretty safe to
say this spell somehow relates to the
ancient magic our player has a unique
ability to perceive and master so my
guess for avadikadavra is that it's one
of these finisher type spells we don't
have the specifics for how they'll be
used but just from the name finisher
alone i think it's likely these won't be
something we can cast at any time
they'll likely be something we have to
build up to either through some type of
combo meter or it could just be purely a
timing thing we have to wait out i think
it's also probable that these finishing
spells will be situational and probably
unavailable in some scenarios but that
still leaves us with two other
unforgivable curses imperio and crucio
with the vodka dabber confirmed it's
only natural for fans to immediately
start wondering what about the other two
let's start with imperial which i think
has some pretty clear utility that would
work very well in a video game the
imperius curse is said to place the
victim completely under the caster's
control the victim is put into a
trance-like state and becomes very
suggestible to the commands of the
caster however those who are
strong-willed may learn to resist it in
the series we've seen this used in very
short bursts but have also heard of it
being used over long periods of time to
essentially imprison other humans
against their will as far as gameplay
goes you wouldn't expect imperio to fall
in the same finisher category as a
vadakadavra instead i think we could see
it being used for various stealth or
puzzle sections in the game let's
imagine a possible mission that maybe
requires the player to enter the
library's restricted section or perhaps
a common room other than the one they
belong to there could be multiple ways
to go about the mission with some
focusing on the light path and others
focusing on a darker path light options
could include things like trying to get
permission from a teacher maybe
polyjuice potion or even an invisibility
cloak the dark path though how about the
imperious curse maybe imperio against a
teacher or an older student to try and
gain access to this area there are
really so many possibilities for
imperial if implemented correctly i
think this one could offer some truly
unique gameplay moments for those that
go down the dark path and then the
question becomes we do see harry ron and
hermione use this in the series as well
so should it be locked away only on the
dark path i think that's certainly an
interesting debate because yes while
harry ron and hermione may have been
justified in needing to use the curse in
the moment they did it is still
considered an unforgivable curse and
almost certainly falls under the dark
magic category but then we have crucio
also known as the torture curse now this
one we get a perfect description of how
this curse works and what it makes the
other person feel when voldemort casts
it on harry in harry potter and the
goblet of fire voldemort raised his wand
and before harry could do anything to
defend himself before he could even move
he had been hit again by the cruciatus
curse the pain was so intense so
all-consuming that he no longer knew
where he was white-hot knives were
piercing every inch of his skin his head
was surely going to burst with pain he
was screaming more loudly than he'd ever
screamed in his life so hearing that
crucio could potentially work as a
finisher but i think it more likely that
we could use this in the dark path as
maybe a way to render attackers
incapacitated in the middle of a fight
perhaps i mean if they wanted to go
really dark maybe even as a way of
extracting useful information from them
that could be beneficial for the story
while these three curses are what fans
typically think of when it comes to the
dark arts the arts themselves actually
go far deeper the harry potter wiki
defines the dark arts as any type of
magic that is primarily used to cause
harm exert control over or even take the
life of another living human or creature
and while the dark arts do usually refer
to spells there are also dark potions
dark creatures and of course horcruxes
which are quite possibly the most
sinister form of magic in the entire
wizarding world even more so than the
unforgivable curses themselves author jk
rowling has only given vague
descriptions of how one would create
such an item refusing to ever fully
reveal the details because of how
horrific the process is it's been
reported that she did reveal the steps
to making a horcrux tour editor and that
the editor promptly felt like vomiting
afterwards as for dark potions fans need
only to look at the end of harry potter
and the half-blood prince for an example
of such a potion in order to retrieve
slytherin's locket in the cave
dumbledore must drink the emerald green
potion which has become known as the
drink of despair the locket cannot be
retrieved until the entire potion has
been drunk while dumbledore drinks the
potion he quickly devolves into a
weakened and terrified state so much so
that he only wants to stop drinking the
potion of course immediately after this
moment we're introduced to one of the
darkest creatures in the wizarding world
in fury they are corpses dead bodies
that have been bewitched to do a dark
wizards bidding and fury have been
confirmed to be in hogwarts legacy in
fact we actually see them in the
gameplay trailer but it's unknown who
created them in this time period you see
infuriate are not naturally recurring
and only exist when a dark witch or
wizard has reanimated them with a dark
curse trailers shown thus far for
hogwarts legacy have led fans to believe
that the goblin ran rock and his
rebellion is at the heart of the
conflict however within fury present
there's sure to be a dark witch or
wizard pulling some strings behind the
scenes as well is it possibly rookwood
the man who's working with ranrock or
perhaps in classic harry potter fashion
it will prove to be someone we first
believe is an ally such as professor
figg or maybe one of the other hogwarts
professors there are countless other
dark creatures we may possibly see in
hogwarts legacy dementors were shown in
the first trailer but haven't been
mentioned since acromantula were also
seen very briefly in that same trailer
of course there are werewolves boggarts
red caps lethal folds banshees basilisks
and plenty more hogwarts legacy has
already revealed quite a few creatures
that are confirmed to be in the game so
it wouldn't surprise me at all to see
more of these dark creatures show up
when we finally get our hands on the
game and while i think there are some
pretty clear applications for dark magic
when it comes to the finishers i
actually think the more challenging one
to think about is finishers for the
light side so that's something we're
going to explore in a future video and
as always thank you so much for watching
i'll talk to you again soon